Unit 7--this unit is going to be kind of a grab bag of things I didn't get to cover
in this class and lectures up until now.
Basically, it's going to be real-world issues and some decisions--
what I look for in a web framework, how we host our stuff--
things like that and some of the decision-making process.
And we also spent a lot of time talking about Reddit.
How we grew it to the extent that we can explain that and how we grew the architecture.
And we'll also do a couple of interviews, one with my friend Neil,
who is the lead engineer at Reddit now.
Another one with Udacity, the engineers at Udacity,
who will explain how they use App Engine in the real world.
Now, I've only use App Engine really in the context of teaching this course,
and built a number of small toy websites now.
But, these guys can actually talk about what is like to use App Engine in production
on a site with thousands of users.
There will be no quizzes. This is just for you to sit back and watch.
If these things don't interest you, just skip ahead to the homework.
If these things do interest you, welcome. It should be fun.